and I see exchange at the State
of the Union this week when Utah
senator Mitt Romney confronted first term
New York Congressman George Santos Romney
telling Santos he does not belong in
Congress Santos has been caught in a
web of alleged lies about his background
since winning his election in November
he said he says he you know that he embellished
his record look embellishing is saying you've got
an A when you get an A minus lying is saying
you you graduated from a college you didn't
even attend and he shouldn't be in Congress
and they're going to go through the process
and hopefully get him out uh but he shouldn't be
there and Santos responded to Romney's criticism
it's not the first time in history that I've
been told to shut up and go to the background
especially by people who come from a privileged
background uh and it's not going to be the last
and I'm never going to shut up and go to the back
of the room and I think it's reprehensible that
the senator would say such a thing to me in the
demeaning way he said it wasn't very Mormon of
him that's what I can tell you I'm not under any
ethics investigation in that same exchange where
the reporter Santos did not answer about whether
his mother was in the World Trade Center on 9 11.
that alleged falsehood falsehood is one of many
Santos is accused of telling voters Santos's rise
to Congress and the controversy following his
election is the subject of a new documentary by
CBS reports in campaign of Deceit Caitlin Huey
Burns tracked through Santos's past to try to
find some answers she is here with more Caitlyn
good morning good morning Jeff well we traveled
throughout Santos's District on New York's
Long Island speaking to constituents political
insiders journalists and even acquaintances and
we even visited Brazil where Santos once lived
but often times even when we found some
answers they often led to more questions
Congressman do you have a response to New York
we're still calling for you to step down since the
34 year olds Congressional win many of the stories
Santos told on the campaign Trail have been
exposed as outright lies you have more Republicans
from New York Brazil asking you to step down
George Anthony devalder Santos never worked at
Citigroup he was not worth a hundred million
dollars when he was 30. we don't know for sure but
he probably wasn't a preferred buyer at Hermes he
didn't attend the Horace Mann school his mother
wasn't in the World Trade Center on 9 11. he
wasn't the descendant of Holocaust Survivors he
never went to Baruch College and George Santos
never won a volleyball championship really who
he is he's a fraud Grant Lally runs the North
Shore leader the newspaper that during Santos's
campaign published what was otherwise discussed
only in Whispers in Republican circles she
began to be known as George scantos among
those who paid attention George scantos correct
my old campaign manager called me up out of the
blue in the middle of this campaign and he said
Grant what is this this is not a campaign this
is a beach party on hotels in Florida alone
Santos's campaign spent more than 11 thousand
dollars part of the more than three million
dollars his campaign spent during his run we
know from his 2020 filings he didn't have any
money at all and then all of a sudden in 2022
he claims to have come into a lot of money yeah
I mean that that was really the the moment that
that really hit us that there's really something
wrong here was when his campaign Finance filings
claimed that he made a seven hundred thousand
dollar loan to his campaign prosecutors at the
Fed federal state and local level are now
investigating a watchdog group filed this
complaint with the Federal Election Commission
questioning Santos's expenses and the source
of the funds he loaned his campaign around the
time he loaned that money Santos was doing this
Harbor City capital before it was alleged to
be a classic Ponzi scheme and shut down by
the Securities and Exchange Commission George
Santos was the regional director in New York
he has said he wasn't aware of any wrongdoing
after the federal prosecutors shut down Harbor
City capital Santos to form new companies together
with Nancy marks down in Florida Nancy marks who
is she she was Santos's campaign Treasurer she
filed all of his reports which means she should
have known whether they were true or false when
she filed them as the treasurer and she had that
legal responsibility hi Nancy we reached out to
Nancy Mark several times and never heard back
so we showed up at a meeting for a Long Island
library where she serves as a board member
when we arrived her seat was empty so we
knocked on the door where she runs her business
the lights were on inside the political posters
hung in the windows but nobody came to the door
George Santos didn't lie only while running
for congress we crisscrossed New York City
and Long Island digging into his past
and found a trail of bitterness women
and men once close to Santos who say they'd
been burned by his falsehoods and betrayals
Caitlyn as we saw there welcome first of all
great to see you thank you good to see you too
as we saw there you tracked down a lot of leads
what what else did you learn about George Santos
well we know what's been out there and what we've
been reporting but we talked to people who knew
him and one compelling character was a woman who
went to middle school with George Santos and she
said that he exhibited these characteristics from
a young age that he would exaggerate fabricate to
try to fit in that he was bullied as a child and
tried to kind of try to fit in with these groups
and she sees a lot of parallels between the
person she saw then and the person she sees
now I know you reached out to him he declined
comment but I mean what what does he say about
this mountain of evidence against him well I do
want to make clear we have tried multiple times
to ask him for an interview and he declined we
caught up with him in the basement of the Capitol
last week to ask him more questions as you can
see and he wasn't responding to our questions
but here's the thing he has said he is sorry for
fabricating getting parts of his resume but it
is much more than that he said that his mother
was in the towers on 9 11 when she wasn't he
claimed his parents were Holocaust Survivors
and when we talked to people in the district
those are the kinds of things that really
hit them because everybody in his district
has a connection to 911 for example and it just
was kind of became personal and Caitlin we know
quickly here there's calls for him to resign
but is there any recourse because it doesn't
seem like he's going to resign here's the really
interesting thing you can't recall your member
of Congress and as much as his constituents
want him to resign they came to DC this week
to try to force him out unless leadership moves
and and they won't they want the investigations
to play out and that's something to really
keep an eye on here but for voters those are
the people who are really disadvantaged in this
just have to vote amount thank you Caitlin and
you can stream campaign of Deceit tomorrow
night at eight Eastern on the CBS News app